[Musik]
der äquator mit globetrotter darm
spezialist für maßgeschneiderte reise
wald wie globetrotter punkt ch
es ist sonntag zeit für die schönsten
kleider marieke serie trägt die show
cars die traditionellen tücher welche
die massai frauen von handbestickten und
übers kreuz umbinden auch gürtel und
schmuck hat mary selbst gefertigt ich
gehe zur kirche
deshalb ziehe ich mich um wir glauben
dass sauberkeit so wichtig ist wie
schönheit wenn ich zur kirche gehe ziehe
ich saubere und schöne kleider
in der ersten folge haben wir mary in
ihren ferien zu hause kennen gelernt im
alter von elf jahren wurde sie von ihrem
lehrer vor einer zwangsheirat gerettet
jetzt bekommt sie die chance zu einer
ausbildung als touristenführerin in
singapur sind wir in das pralle leben
der ärztin georgi eingetaucht
die glamour lady macht mich
schönheitsbehandlungen millionen
in den weiten des pazifischen ozeans
droht die inselgruppe keepers wegen des
klimawandels unterzugehen
doch die bewohner sind sich dieser
gefahr noch wenig bewusst
auf galapagos schließlich lebt
touristenführer matthias espinosa seine
herausforderung ist es das fragile
gleichgewicht zwischen natur und
tourismus zu erhalten
[Musik]
marieke serien auf dem weg zur kirche
heute ist ihr letzter ferientag hier
trifft sie freunde und bekannte
[Musik]
ja
das beten und singen in der gemeinschaft
helfe ihr erzählt mary die düsteren
gedanken zu verdrängen
[Musik]
nein
naja
hi
[Musik]
nach dem kirchgang kehrt mary noch
einmal zurück in die ärmliche hütte ihre
mutter morgen geht es wieder in die
schule für sie die große chance
ich muss meine sachen packen
in diesem buch habe ich während meiner
ferien gelesen und meine hausaufgaben
gemacht aber nur in der nacht weil ich
am tag keine zeit hatte weil ich meine
mutter geholfen haben das buch heißt
vögel von kenia und tansania
ich liebe es hier deshalb hatte ich es
jetzt schon ein damit ich es morgen
sicher nicht vergessen
[Musik]
in singapur hat die ärztin george ali
nach einer 80 stunden arbeitswoche wie
sie sagt ihren freien tag zusammen mit
der haushälterin kocht sie für die
familie
madame kieswerk die aus indonesien lebt
und arbeitet schon seit 18 jahren im
hause liegen
wir haben eine freundschaft wie sie
zwischen frauen üblich ist
manchmal brauchen wir gar nicht zu
sprechen sie kann meine stimmungen sehr
gut lesen manchmal spürt sie dass ich
einen whiskey brauche manchmal sitzt sie
einfach neben mir
ich komme oft spät nach hause es scheint
als ob sie immer weiß was ich für die
nacht brauche ich dann meine liebe
mehr
[Musik]
während die junge masai frau mary am
sonntag in der kirche betet findet
george ali seit kurzem yoga zu ihrer
spiritualität
[Musik]
sucht die 45 jährige für die das
aussehen so wichtig ist plötzlich die
erfüllung in der inneren schönheit wenn
ich mich äußerlich schön finde fühle ich
mich auch innerlich gut für mich ist es
eine mischung
ich glaube nicht dass ich mich gut
fühlen könnte wenn ich nicht gut
aussehen würde
also ich sage nicht dass ich schön bin
aber ich versuche mein bestes das ist
george alice ehemann pierre christen ipm
ein anästhesist seit 18 jahren sind sie
verheiratet gemeinsame stunden finden
sie höchstens an sonntagen wie kann das
funktionieren
[Musik]
über den inselstaat kiribati ist ein
sturm hinweg gezogen
katar könnte tacke und seine frau jutta
biener hatten eine schlaflose nacht
das meer hat seine krallen gezeigt
doch beklagen mag sich katter nicht
unser schicksal liegt in gottes hand
er entscheidet
er allein weiß was er mit uns vorhat und
es wird so kommen die ihr entscheidet
das haus der familie liegt bei flut nur
wenige zentimeter vom meer entfernt
selbst bei sturm und tiefschwarzer nacht
gehört für katar der morgendliche gang
ins meer zum alltag auf der insel auf
caritas ist das meer teil des lebens es
ernährt die menschen und doch ist es
ihre größte gefahr
der montag ist ein besonderer tag einmal
pro woche arbeitet katar für einige
stunden am flugplatz dafür villa
blitzsauber sein
die arbeit als hilfskraft am flughafen
bringt jeden monat 40 fanden ein
immerhin nicht nur deshalb hängt die
hoffnung der ganzen familie daran
das ist vielleicht nur ein kleiner job
aber ich bin froh dass ich ihn habe
so kann ich zeigen dass ich mir mühe
geben
das ist auch für zukünftige
vorstellungsgespräche wichtig so kann
ich vielleicht eine richtige arbeit
finden um eine familie zu ernähren
am heutigen tag wird katar am flughafen
auf menschen treffen die für ihn nicht
nur gutes bringen
[Musik]
auf galapagos touristenführer matthias
espinosa unterwegs mit dem tauchboot
aggressor er stimmt seine gäste ein auf
eine begegnung der ganz besonderen art
der einzige grund weshalb die meerechsen
von galapagos nicht so groß wie
krokodile werden also vier meter lang
ist el niño
dieser kommt alle 12 bis 14 jahre
bernd das wasser und setzt die
meerechsen unter druck es gibt wenig
nahrung und die größten sterben
mit dem schlauchboot will sich matthias
ein besseres bild des echsen bestandes
machen die klippen sind voll davon
hoch auf dem felsen thronen sie fast
majestätisch
bald den galapagos inseln kommen
verschiedene meeresströmungen zusammen
warme und kalte deshalb variiert die
wassertemperatur hier vor der insel
fernandina steigt der kalt der cromwell
strom aus der tiefsee hoch er bringt
reichlich nahrung mit ist aber mit knapp
20 grad ziemlich kalt für die max
die reptilien kamen vor zehn millionen
jahren auf die idee zurück ins meer zu
gehen und haben sich immer mehr an das
neue element angepasst die meerechsen
sind wechselwarm ihre körpertemperatur
hängt von der umgebung ab auf den
klippen heizen sie sich auf bis zu einer
körpertemperatur von circa 38 grad
erst dann sind sie bereits im kalten
wasser nach nahrung zu suchen
dieses naturphänomen überwältigt
matthias espinosa immer wieder von neuem
für mich ist der 6 das beispiel der
anpassung weit weg in der mitte vom
pazifik dass diese land extrem von
millionen jahren hergekommen sind und
gemerkt haben aha
es gibt vielleicht wenig zu essen an
land ich muss mich anpassen an das was
unter wasser essbar ist und diese
evolution hat natürlich sehr lange
gedauert aber mittlerweile sind diese ex
natürlich experten in abtauchen
luftanhalten algen verdauen und sogar zu
schrumpfen wenn es hilft wenig nahrung
gibt das ist einmalig auf der welt
wie sieht es aus wenn diese uhr fischer
unter wasser ihr mittagessen einnehmen
matthias und seine tauch gäste können es
kaum erwarten
[Musik]
im hause li ist das sonntägliche
mittagessen der fixpunkt der woche vater
pierre christian und die söhne george
und pierre sehen ehefrauen mutter julie
oftmals tagelang nicht
sie haben sich daran gewöhnt und können
sich arrangieren
meistens jedenfalls
gehen wir zusammen star trek schauen
nächste woche ich komme am wochenende
zurück
ich glaube ich so lange warten
es ist eine samstagabend-show pia
christian hat das anästhesist ein
komplett anderes leben als seine frau
mit ihrer beauty und mode welt hat er
nicht viel am hut
ich bin nicht sehr in mode interessiert
aber ich versuche ein bisschen am ball
zu bleiben
viele leute fragen mich ob meine frau
meine kleider auswählt ich sage dann
nein ich lasse ihnen ihren eigenen stil
wenn du jemanden zu stark verändert ist
es nicht mehr der selbe mann den du
geheiratet hat er ist immer gut
er gleicht mich aus und zeigt mir vor
und nachteile hat sich noch junge gehört
sich nicht so stark auf ihn
jetzt sehe ich den wert seiner
ratschläge er ist wirklich ein toller
ehemann vater und sie sind sie eine gute
mutter
ich bin keine glocke ich bin kein rebell
tante diesmal die jungs manchmal bin ich
mit ihren entscheidungen nicht
einverstanden aber ich sage erst mal
nichts
sie sollen es selber herausfinden sich
interveniert dann wenn ich wirklich
denke es ist nötig und dann hören sie
auch ist es nicht so im vergleich zu
anderen müttern bin ich keinen
nun ist ja ja es wird ein kurzer
gemeinsamer sonntag schon bald
übernehmen wieder die stylisten von
george ali das zepter
[Musik]
der flugplatz von kiri bass zweimal pro
woche erwacht er zum leben immer dann
wenn der einzige internationale flug von
fidschi kommt und einmal pro woche darf
kater im flughafen team mitarbeiten
quasi als mädchen für alles das tor zur
großen weiten welt
[Musik]
natürlich würde ich auch gerne mal
verreisen und ein anderes land sehen
aber leben möchte ich nirgendwo anders
als hier
abgesehen davon könnte ich mir eine
reise niemals leisten
die landung des flugzeugs aus der
anderen welt ist ein insel ereignis
[Musik]
aus dem flugzeug steigen vor allem weiße
jahr für jahr werden es nie
[Musik]
als sie schon einen transport kann
er hat dort drüben war gut
ich sehe dass immer mehr weiße zu uns
kommen
aber warum die alle kommen ehrlich
gesagt keine ahnung auf der
touristischen weltkarte ist carey was
nicht vorhanden
wohl aber auf jener der klimaforscher
und nach und nach spürt katar das mit
seiner insel etwas nicht stimmen kann
mein land soll untergehen wenn das
wirklich so ist macht mich das sehr
traurig was soll denn dann muss man den
kindern und enkelkindern wir was kater
nicht weiß im selben moment erfährt
seine frau wieso das meer immer mehr
steigt und caritas schon in ein paar
jahrzehnten unbewohnbar sein könnte 8600
kilometer weiter entfernt sind die
taucher um matthias espinosa bereit für
ein naturspektakel der archaischen art
das tauchen mit den meerechsen
[Musik]
im 19 grad kalten wasser hält die echse
es nur etwa eine halbe stunde aus dann
schaltet ihr blut und sie hat mühe sich
zu bewegen
[Musik]
nach einigen minuten muss das
faszinierende reptil zurück an die
oberfläche um luft zu schnappen
gierig frist die echse saftige halten
das passt einen kleinen refresh
überhaupt nicht er versucht seine alben
wiese zu verteidigen
aber was soll er tun gegen dieses
ungetüm aus der urzeit
[Musik]
auch wenn mehrere rief barsche
protestieren
die meerechsen lassen sich durch nichts
und niemanden stören
sie fressen weiter denn ihre zeit ist
knapp und ihr bedarf groß
ein naturschauspiel wie aus einer
anderen zeit
zeit zum träumen bleibt nicht lange nur
noch wenige meilen und dann überqueren
matthias und seine gäste den äquator das
dorf sec an anni liegt auf halbem weg
zwischen merici series weiler und der
schule an der sie ihre ausbildung zur
safari guide macht dorthin geht sie aber
nie bevor sie nicht beim friseur war für
die schule wird aus dem bauernmädchen
mary eine elegante junge dame
zuerst gilt es die passenden kunst haare
auszusuchen zu lesen
lasst uns mission diese farbe und diese
die haare kosten 200 schilling das
flechten 610 fanden kostet marys
verwandlung ein kleines vermögen welches
einen bruder für sie immer zu
schulbeginn aufbringt wie willst du die
mischung direkt im topf oder mit
verschiedenen töpfen und verschiedenen
farben
ich will den sub gemischt
wird es lange dauern
du willst nicht zu spät sein kleiner
angst natürlich sehe ich anders aus wenn
ich in der schule ganz bin ich zu hause
bin in der schule merke ich ja nicht
werde also nicht schmutzig ich muss dort
nur zum unterricht gehen und mit den
geflochtenen haaren brauche ich nicht
lange ich stehe am morgen auf wasche
mich und sehr gut aus ich bin bereit zum
lernen wie die anderen le dieser
[Musik]
in singapur hat georgia lee derweil ganz
andere sorten habe ich dieses kleid
wirklich das ist ein sehr altes es ist
von georgi besitzt tausende von kleidern
alle fein säuberlich dokumentiert sie
sucht mit ihrem stylisten ein passendes
kostüm für eine modenschau am abend wir
könnten etwas im 70er jahre look
versuchen das ist wieder sehr stylisch
george arbeitet schon sieben jahre
ausschließlich für charlie arbeit hat er
mehr als genug
frau doktor zieht sich gerne mehrmals am
tag um und jedes kleid trägt sie in der
öffentlichkeit nur einmal pro land diese
rote robe von dior couture kam bislang
noch nicht zum einsatz
[Musik]
in kenia sitzt die frisur perfekt mary
ist bereit für die schule
doch jetzt heißt es warten warten auf
den geländewagen der sie dorthin fährt
doch viele autos hier sind in einem
schlechten zustand
statt straßen ziehen sich staubige
pisten durch das land thema sei der
wagen muss schüler in den entlegensten
gegenden abholen
und so wartet mary und sie wartet und
wartet
bis weit nach sonnenuntergang der
geländewagen endlich kommt und mary ins
internat in berühmten masai mara
nationalpark fährt
[Musik]
stylist jorge angehört bei treasury
schon längst zur familie
wenn es um fragen nach dem perfekten
auftritt geht ist er der wichtigste mann
in ihrem leben
dennoch auf die meinung ihres ehemannes
will sie trotzdem nicht verzichten
wo ist grüßen
was denkst du über dieses kleid
ich kann es bei einem dinner tragen
ehemann chris ist amüsiert über die
ernsthaftigkeit mit der seine frau
kleider probiert sie lebten auf zwei
verschiedenen planeten sagt er später
abseits der kamera und doch könne er
sich keine bessere partner in vorstellen
georgi und ihr ehemann haben das
materiell zu etwas gebracht gehören zu
den oberen zehntausend im singapur
sie können sich ein leben leisten wie
nur ganz wenige menschen entlang des
äquators
ich bin mir immer bewusst dass sich ein
prämiertes leben habe
aber ich vergesse die leute um mich
herum nicht und ich schäme mich nicht
was ich privilegiert bin wenn du fleißig
bist und erfolgreich dann kannst du mehr
leuten helfen
so versuche ich hart zu arbeiten
das ist für mich sehr wichtig
und während mary in kenia im
geländewagen durch die nacht holpert
lässt sich georgia auf ihre weise
richtung downtown singapur chauffieren
[Musik]
nobelkarossen hat auf der insel clippers
wohl noch kaum jemand gesehen
hier läuft die zeit anders motto wiener
bringt ihre enkelkinder zur schule
gemächliches tempo kein wunder es ist
kurz vor acht uhr und bereits 40 grad
heiß
[Musik]
auf dem lehrplan
viele gesang und umweltschutz wir gehen
mit den kindern viel raus in die natur
dort entfernen wir den müll von anderen
wir bringen den kindern bei dass die
natur etwas wertvolles ist mit dem man
sorgsam umgehen muss klimaforscher sagen
voraus dass das land dieser kinder noch
in diesem jahrhundert nicht mehr
bewohnbar sein wird und das erfahren
jutta biener und die anderen eltern und
großeltern in diesem augenblick
ich möchte mit euch über den klimawandel
sprechen den spüren wir sind die opfer
des klimawandels uns trifft es zuerst
klären terrier ist umweltaktivistin sie
will jene aufklären die sonst keinen
zugang haben zu informationen über den
klimawandel
ich will euch das mit dem klimawandel
erklären das ist in etwa so wie wenn man
ein auto in der prallen sonne stehen
lässt die heiße luft kann nicht mehr
raus wenn man da ein eis im auto hat
schmilzt es und genau so läuft das auf
der erde
das eis schmilzt wie in einem heißen
auto
was bedeutet das konkret für uns für die
antwort hat claire den einzigen globus
der insel aufgetrieben
das hier oben ist der nordpol
da schmilzt das eis hier seht ihr das
eis schmilzt und fließt ins meer
dadurch steigt natürlich der
meeresspiegel an auf der ganzen welt
und so bekommen länder wie carrie
bastian ein problem
sie gehen unter das betrifft die ganze
wert wir sind vielleicht die ersten die
es trifft aber nach uns wird es andere
länder treffen und danach wieder andere
lass uns doch mal schauen wo kiri
passgenau liegt und das ist schon gar
nicht mehr drauf das ist der äquator da
bist du ja mein caritas es ist schwer
vorzustellen dass carey bass untergeht
weil am nordpol das eis schmilzt das
dass bis hierher nach caritas
konsequenzen
es ist schlimm dass wir hier darunter
leiden müssen
[Musik]
hier herrscht aufbruchstimmung der erste
schultag nach den ferien 20 junge
kenianer werden zurzeit an der kieskuhle
zu guides ausgebildet
ich werde mit naturkunde anfangen
wir haben nicht viel zeit bis zur
prüfung im klassenraum sitzen nur masai
wie mary andere schüler werden nicht
aufgenommen
das hat einen grund das problem war dass
es vor allem kenianer aus anderen
landesteilen und multinationale
reisekonzerne waren die vom geldsegen
des tourismus profitierten diese leute
lernten den schulen alles über tiere und
tourismus die masse aber die hier seit
jeher leben waren ausgeschlossen
sie wussten zwar schon immer viel über
tiere und pflanzen aber nicht wie man
dies den gästen vermitteln
genau das will die schule beheben
die meisten schulabgänger haben im
tourismusbereich eine arbeit gefunden
auch alle jungen frauen dies obwohl
viele von ihnen wie mary einen harten
weg hinter sich haben
ich bin sehr glücklich dass ich in der
schule sein darf ich habe eine chance
bekommen hier zu sein
ich liebe das lernen und es macht mich
sehr freuen wenn ich zu hause wäre hätte
ich jetzt viele kinder wäre verheiratet
worden und würde nur zu den kindern
schauen neun jahre gibt es die aus
spendengeldern finanzierte schule
bereits nun können die lehrer
feststellen dass ihre institution spuren
hinterlässt in der masai gemeinschaft
die absolventen können dank der schule
ihren lebensstandard verbessern
sie können gute häuser bauen und ihre
kinder in die schule schicken
sie leben gut und können ihre familien
selbst ernähren
das hat einen großen wert danke vielmals
später guten appetit auf dem weg zu
ihrer unabhängigkeit lernt mary schon
bald etwas das kaum eine masse frau
beherrscht
[Musik]
in singapur haben die leute geld geld
das ausgegeben werden will zum beispiel
für eine schönheitsbehandlung bei dr
georgia bis zu 60 patienten entfernt sie
pro tag
sie ist auf drei monate hinaus
ausgebucht
fast die hälfte der patienten fliegen
extra nach singapur um von ihr behandelt
zu werden geschenke aus aller welt
zeugen davon
der tisch ist feng shui diese fische
sind kampfes wir wollen diesen
kampfgeist ihm das ist sehr wichtig für
mich
ich will dass alle meine girls
kämpferinnen sind ich sage zu ihnen wie
ich es auch meinen kindern sage im leben
kannst du dich entscheiden entweder du
bist ein arbeiter oder du bist ein
general
du hast eine strategie und bewegt etwas
so will ich dass alle meine girls
kämpferinnen bzw generäle sind in ihrem
bereich wir wollen nicht mittelmäßig
seien zwischen den behandlungen nimmt
frau doktor ihre girls wie sie sie nennt
immer wieder zur brust
motivationstraining es scheint zu
funktionieren denn die meisten arbeiten
schon seit vielen jahren hier
gestern hatte ich ein treffen mit einem
verleger wir machen vielleicht ein buch
zusammen
da habe ich diese notizbücher gesehen
hier heißt es ich bin nicht
anspruchsvoll ich bin bloß ein
perfektionist
seid nicht schüchtern wenn ihr etwas
wollt fragt danach auch wenn es zehn mal
sein muss ihr denkt sicher manchmal dr
liest ja schrecklich aber ich mache
keine kompromisse wenn ich denke wir
schaffen das will ich dran bleiben bis
es richtig ist
und gleich im anschluss an das meeting
passiert etwas was für europäische geist
mit ihren werken bitte bereitet meine
botox behandlung vor
schon gemacht ich mache eine behandlung
an mir selber in nächster zeit habe ich
viele interviews und meine haut wird
etwas schlaf ich spüre nicht dass ich
älter werde ich will einfach gut
aussehen
ich genieße mein alter mehr als früher
ich bin in meinem denken weiter und
weniger ungeduldig in der vergangenheit
war ich sehr ungeduldig mit den leuten
weil ich dachte sie geben nicht ihr
bestes
heute weiß ich jeder hat seine grenzen
und lebt sein eigenes leben
also kann ich sie nicht dazu zwingen es
in meinem stil zu machen
außerdem arbeiten für mich
ich spreche nur wenig so dass sich das
gesicht gut bewegen kann und nicht wie
gefroren aussehe
am morgen yoga für die innere schönheit
am nachmittag botox für das äußere das
gehört zum produkt george ali wie sie es
selbst erschaffen hat ich traue niemand
anderen
also spritze ich selber diese seite ist
okay
das war's botox spritzen in georgia ließ
kreisen so selbstverständlich wie für
unser ein das zähneputzen da vorne
irgendwo liegt die magische linie der
äquator
ob im flugzeug oder per schiff die
äquator überquerung ist immer ein
kleines ereignis das ist auch auf der
kommandobrücke der aggressor nicht
anders
[Musik]
auf dieser nordseite entführt uns
matthias espinosa in der nächsten folge
zu den hammerhaien und erzählt über den
schockierenden illegalen fischfang auf
kiras versuchen die bewohner ihre insel
so gut wie möglich zu schützen und der
präsident erklärt uns wie er mit dem
untergangsszenario umgeht
in kenia muss sich mary am steuer eines
jeeps beweisen
in singapur will george ali mit
kosmetikprodukten den ganzen asiatischen
markt erobern
und wir lernen nun kennen
er will in borneo das letzte stückchen
urwald seines volkes retten
dafür kämpft er auch gegen den eigenen
staat
dies und mehr in der nächsten folge von
der äquator breitengrad der extreme
[Musik]
der äquator mit globetrotter darm
spezialist für maßgeschneiderte reise
war mit globetrotter punkt ch